you have studied Beyonce extensively I
studied her career like probably more
than any like thesis or whatever I did
in school like 20 years how did she stay
relevant and the biggest thing I saw is
that she is so good at adapting work
from so many different sources around
the world essentially if you study like
single ladies that video that took off
Kanye called it like one of the best
videos of all time it actually comes
from 1969 but what's fascinating is like
she didn't go through the 1960s Archive
of like studying Bob fosty choreography
she saw a djun remix of that to walk out
so like she saw a remix of the original
and made her own remix everybody's
talking about copy and paste she's all
about copy with taste